hay algunos gorilas levantando pesas en
el gimnasio después entran tres gorilas
más y comienzan a correr ahora tenemos
17 gorilas en el gimnasio cuántos
gorilas están levantando pesas
estos son los gorilas que estaban en el
gimnasio desde el principio levantando
pesas aquí tengo este diagrama cuántos
cuadrados tenemos 1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10
11 12 13 14 15 16 17 cuadrados que son
los gorilas que hay ahorita en el
gimnasio
tenéis gorilas entraron y comenzaron a
correr quizá estos tres son los gorilas
que entraron después así que cuánto
sabía antes pues todos los cuadros que
no rellene la respuesta es 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
8 9 10 11 12 13 y 14 así que había 14
gorilas levantando peces en el gimnasio
aquí están los 3 que entraron después
que comenzaron a correr lo que nos da un
total de 17 cuadros nuestra respuesta es
14 hay otras formas de resolver esto por
ejemplo tenemos un número de gorilas que
ya se encuentran en el gimnasio en
nuestra interrogante más tres gorilas
que entran después y ahora serán 17
gorilas así que podemos decir que algo
más 3 nos da 17
otra forma sería 17 menos tres que
entraron después
nos va a dar la cantidad de gorilas que
estaban desde el principio que es igual
a nuestro interrogante de cualquier
manera nos va a dar 14 17 menos 3 17 son
una decena y siete unidades menos tres
unidades 7 menos 34 así que 17 menos 3
es 14 resolvamos otro problema como los
que se encuentran en kant academy y es
bueno saber qué es lo que preguntan
compre una bolsa con 13 chocolates
mi hermana se comió varios de ellos y
solo me quedaron ocho chocolates cuántos
chocolates comió mi hermana aquí está la
cantidad de chocolates todavía no sé
cuánto se comió cuáles opciones que
pueden ayudar a resolver el problema
elije todas las que apliquen y aquí
están las opciones entonces ana tomó los
datos tenía una bolsa con 13 chocolates
mi hermana comió algunos no sé cuántos
comió este es mi interrogante y me
quedaron ocho chocolates
s - algo me da 8 o podemos verlo como
que queremos resolver la interrogante
quizás algunos de ustedes ya encontraron
que 13 menos 5 de 8 y que la
interrogante es igual a 5 o podemos
decir que 13 menos 8 es igual a nuestro
interrogante también podemos decir que
me quedé con ocho chocolates mi hermana
comió algunos aquí sumo mi interrogante
que es lo que tengo más lo que se comió
mi hermana y tendré la cantidad de
chocolates que tenía al inicio igual a
13 de cualquier manera encontraremos que
nuestra interrogante será igual a 5 nos
preguntan cuáles de estas opciones te
pueden ayudar a resolver el problema si
sabemos que la interrogante es 5 y
sabemos que 13 menos 5 nos da 8
reemplazaremos esto con 5 13 menos 5 es
igual a 8
este es un enunciado verdadero esta
segunda opción si me sirve
comencé con tres chocolates mi hermana
comió cinco y me quedaron ocho
chocolates
y aquí 13 menos 8 es igual a 5
aquí no tienen esta opción
y ahora 85
es igual a 13 esta si la tenemos y si
nos es útil 8 es lo que tengo 5 son los
que se comió mi hermana y 13 son los que
tenía el principio 13 5 es igual a 18
este no me sirve pues no tiene que ver
con mi problema no es que mi hermana
consiguiera cinco chocolates y melosa
agregará a los 13 que ya tenía y me
quedarán 18 chocolates
solo tengo ocho chocolates porque ella
se comió cinco de los trece que tenía